L'enregistrement, c'est bon.
Donc, ce livre de la Bible s'appelle l'Épitre de Jacques.
Donc c'est Jacques qui l'a écrit, voilà, sans surprise.
Et ce Jacques en question, c'était le demi-frère de Jésus.
Et donc il l'a côtoyé de près, tout au long de son ministère,
sans pour autant être positif à son égard.
Au contraire.
Et c'est juste à la fin du ministère Thérèse de Jésus
que le Saint-Esprit a touché le cœur de Jacques
et qu'il a compris que son demi-frère était le Messie,
le Fils de Dieu incarné.
Et donc Jacques devint, par la suite,
après que le Christ soit monté à la droite du Père,
il devint l'un des premiers pasteurs de l'Église naissante du Nouveau Testament.
Et c'est ce cœur pastoral qui s'exprime avec beaucoup d'amour,
avec beaucoup de zèle dans cette lettre.
Un amour pour le Christ et son peuple,
un zèle pour la sainteté de Dieu et pour celle de son peuple.
Cette lettre est celle d'un vrai pasteur,
celle d'un ministre de l'Évangile
qui se soucie des âmes de ses frères
et qui brûle de les voir conformer leur vie
à la volonté de leur Père Céleste.
Pour Jacques, il n'existe pas d'autre Évangile
que celui qui anéantit notre chair
et qui porte du fruit de l'Esprit.
Si bien que celui qui prétend connaître et aimer Dieu,
mais qui vit comme il l'entend,
s'illusionne complètement quant au salut de son âme.
La foi salvatrice,
celle que nous professons en tant que chrétiens,
se manifeste en nous,
transformant de l'intérieur
afin que nos actes extérieurs glorifient Dieu
et bénissent les hommes.
Notre foi chrétienne,
elle est vivante.
Et donc, par définition,
elle ne peut rester invisible,
elle ne peut rester inerte dans notre quotidien.
C'est pour cette raison que Jacques
fut poussé par le Saint-Esprit
à adresser toutes ces exhortations pratiques,
très diverses,
sur des thèmes très différents
et sur des thèmes qui sont universels
pour tous les chrétiens.
Et le premier de ces sujets,
si vous vous en rappelez,
que Jacques aborde,
c'est la persévérance dans l'épreuve.
Les chrétiens auxquels Jacques s'adresse
sont persécutés par les Juifs,
par les Romains.
Ils ont dû fuir de leur ville,
de la ville où ils habitaient.
Ils ont dû quitter leur foyer,
une partie de leur famille,
certainement de leurs amis.
Bref, ils ont dû renoncer
à une grande partie de leur vie
pour en commencer une nouvelle.
Et une nouvelle beaucoup plus difficile
et bien plus remplie d'épreuves
que la précédente.
Et donc, c'est pour encourager
ses frères face
à cette situation nouvelle
que Jacques leur rappelle,
des versets 1 à 4
que nous avons étudiés.
Pourquoi cela vaut la peine
d'endurer la souffrance,
de persévérer dans l'épreuve ?
Pour le chrétien,
c'est ce que Jacques dit,
l'épreuve a un sens,
elle a une utilité,
elle a un but,
parce qu'elle est un des outils principaux
que Dieu utilise
pour nous sanctifier
en vue de la vie éternelle.
Pour nous, les chrétiens,
l'épreuve n'est pas une option,
elle est encore moins anormale,
une anomalie dans notre vie.
Elle est le passage nécessaire
vers notre conformité au Christ.
Et comme nous le verrons
encore aujourd'hui,
puisque nous allons revenir
sur ce sujet,
des épreuves dans la vie chrétienne,
la récompense pour celui
qui persévère dans l'épreuve
est grande.
Nous avons vu ensuite
que le chrétien ne peut espérer
tenir bon dans ses épreuves,
justement,
et de manière plus générale
dans son exil sur terre,
donc dans toute sa vie,
que s'il prie efficacement.
Et pour cela,
nous avons identifié
trois caractéristiques
d'une prière efficace
que nous devrions tous
travailler à développer
dans nos vies,
parce que prier efficacement,
ça ne s'improvise pas.
Et donc,
une prière chrétienne efficace
doit d'abord être
adressée au seul vrai Dieu,
le Dieu trinitaire,
puis son sujet doit être
en accord et nourri
par les intérêts
de ce seul vrai Dieu.
Et enfin,
troisième caractéristique,
nous devons élever
cette prière vers les cieux
avec la foi qui émane
d'un cœur entier,
d'un cœur sincère,
consacré à Dieu.
Et ce même cœur sincèrement
et entièrement consacré
à Dieu est nécessaire
pour nous prémunir
des grands dangers
que représentent l'argent
et les richesses terrestres
pour notre âme.
C'est ce que nous avons vu
dans la dernière prédication
des versets 9 à 11.
Tout simplement parce que
c'est d'un cœur partagé
entre les cieux et la terre,
entre Dieu et Maman,
que Satan peut se saisir
en le séduisant
par les vaines promesses
des richesses,
en détournant son regard
du ciel
pour le ramener
et le figer sur terre.
Nous avons vu
que les dangers liés
aux richesses,
ils concernent aussi bien
le pauvre que le riche,
parce que la racine
du problème,
ce n'est pas premièrement
le niveau de prospérité,
mais c'est ce cœur
qui est partagé
entre le ciel et la terre
à cause de la corruption
du péché
qui est commune
à tous les hommes.
Et nous avons conclu
en considérant
qu'il était bon
pour nos églises
d'avoir en leur sein
cette diversité
de richesses
que Dieu a voulu
y maintenir,
afin que le plus pauvre
et le plus riche
puissent,
dans leurs conditions
respectives,
dans leurs situations
de prospérité respective,
s'enseigner l'un l'autre
sur ce qu'ils ont
de plus précieux en commun,
l'évangile du Christ.
Voilà, en résumé,
ce que nous avons déjà
pu considérer
dans les premiers versets
de ce texte,
que nous allons donc
reprendre ce matin
en verset 12,
avec cette phrase
qui, encore une fois,
comme c'est souvent le cas
dans cet épître de Jacques,
rappelle beaucoup
les écrits de sagesse
de l'Ancien Testament,
proverbes,
psaumes,
ecclésiastes,
comme au psaume 1,
que nous allons lire
aussi dans quelques instants.
Et cette phrase rappelle
aussi les enseignements
de Jésus,
comme dans le serment
sur la montagne.
Lisons donc
le verset 12.
« Heureux l'homme
qui supporte patiemment
la tentation. »
Souvent,
lorsqu'on retrouve
cette phrase,
cette béatitude,
comme on l'appelle
dans les Écritures,
c'est pour mettre
en contraste
le vrai bonheur
et le vrai malheur,
où le juste
est le méchant,
celui qui est destiné
à la vie,
à la mort.
C'est pour mettre
en place
un contraste net,
une dichotomie.
Je mentionnais
à l'instant
le psaume 1
qui commence
de la même manière.
« Heureux l'homme
qui ne marche pas
selon le conseil
des méchants. »
Et cet homme-là,
dans le psaume 1,
s'oppose à l'homme méchant
qui, lui,
à l'inverse,
sera comme la paille
que l'on chasse au loin,
qui ne subsistera pas
au jour du jugement
et qui périra.
Donc,
cette opposition,
ce contraste,
nous le retrouvons ici
avec Jacques,
dans des termes
qui sont assez similaires.
Il est dit du riche,
qui représente en réalité ici
tout homme dont le cœur
est attaché à ce monde,
attaché à sa vie terrestre,
qu'il passera
comme la fleur de l'herbe,
qu'il se flétrira
dans ses entreprises.
Même si le sujet
est un peu différent
entre le psaume 1
et ses versets en Jacques,
le principe est le même.
Jacques cherche à mettre
en évidence
les finalités
très différentes,
des vies très différentes
de ces deux personnes
très différentes.
D'un côté,
la perdition
et la mort du méchant,
de l'autre,
la restauration
et la vie
du juste.
Et Jacques nous enseigne
ici au verset 12
que le chemin
du juste
qui vivra,
c'est un chemin
semé de tentations
ou d'épreuves
qu'il nous faut
endurer patiemment
pour recevoir
la couronne de vie.
C'est ce que dit
la suite du verset 12.
Car après avoir été
éprouvé,
il recevra
la couronne de vie
que le Seigneur
a promise
à ceux
qui l'aiment.
C'est ce terme
bien connu
dans la foi chrétienne
de tentation
qui va particulièrement
nous intéresser
ce matin.
Non seulement
parce qu'il est central
dans ces versets,
mais parce qu'il peut
avoir plusieurs sens,
comme c'est le cas
d'ailleurs dans ce passage
et dans d'autres
des Écritures.
Et si nous comprenons
mal les différents sens
que ce mot
a du verset 12
au verset 15,
nous allons passer
complètement à côté
de l'exhortation
que Jacques nous adresse.
et en plus,
nous allons construire
une doctrine bancale
de ce mot
qui est si centrale
dans notre foi chrétienne.
Alors,
qu'est-ce que Jacques
entend par là
au verset 12 ?
Eh bien,
comme je le disais,
en réalité,
il revient ici
au premier sujet
qu'il aborde dans sa lettre,
à savoir
les épreuves
de la vie chrétienne.
Mais cette fois-ci,
en mettant
plus clairement l'emphase
sur le but,
sur la finalité
de ces épreuves
que nous endurons
patiemment.
Si vous vous rappelez,
pour ceux qui étaient là
et qui ont une bonne mémoire,
nous avions vu
que seul le chrétien
peut vraiment considérer
l'épreuve
comme un sujet
de joie parfaite.
Et non pas par déni,
non pas par masochisme,
mais bien
parce qu'il sait
que l'épreuve
est décidée,
voulue,
et utilisée par Dieu
pour produire en nous
de la patience.
patience qui,
elle-même,
accomplit son œuvre
de sanctification
en nous
afin que nous soyons prêts
pour la vie éternelle
et que nous ayons part
à la vie éternelle.
Eh bien,
c'est exactement
la même idée
que Jacques reprend ici
par cette béatitude.
Heureux est l'homme
qui persévère
dans la tentation
ou l'épreuve,
ici.
D'ailleurs,
dans certaines bibles,
le mot est traduit
par épreuve
et non tentation.
car quand il aura été éprouvé,
il recevra la couronne de vie
ou la vie éternelle,
puisque c'est synonyme
dans la parole,
que le Seigneur a promise
à ceux qui l'aiment.
En réalité,
nous pourrions faire
une prédication entière
sur ce seul verset,
mais pour ce matin,
il nous suffit
de comprendre
que Jacques réaffirme
essentiellement
la même vérité
que dans ses premiers versets.
Le terme tentation,
s'il est traduit,
comme je le disais,
ainsi dans vos bibles,
est synonyme d'épreuve
et la couronne de vie
est synonyme
de vie éternelle.
Jacques
veut nous encourager
à nouveau
à tenir bon,
à persévérer,
à endurer patiemment
parce que cela
en vaut la peine.
Et si cela n'était pas
suffisamment clair
au verset 3,
il rappelle à ses lecteurs,
ses lecteurs que nous sommes
aujourd'hui,
que notre persévérance
n'est pas vaine
et que nous devons garder
les yeux fixés
sur la récompense,
sur la joie parfaite
qui nous attend
dans les cieux
au retour du Christ.
Jacques nous encourage
en faisant le lien
entre notre persévérance
dans l'épreuve ici-bas
et la vie éternelle
que nous aurons
auprès du Christ.
Dans cette perspective-là,
nos épreuves deviennent
comme des fenêtres ouvertes
sur les cieux
où notre joie sera parfaite.
Car alors même,
les épreuves les plus dures
ont un sens,
une utilité,
un but et nous sommes
encouragés et fortifiés
par le Saint-Esprit
à tenir bon
parce que nous savons
que Dieu éprouve
ceux qu'il aime.
Parce que c'est précisément
en nous éprouvant
que Dieu nous émonde,
qu'il nous perfectionne,
qu'il nous purifie
comme l'argent
dans le creuset
et qu'il nous rend aptes
à courir la course
jusqu'au bout,
ce qui est l'objectif
de tout chrétien.
Dieu discipline
et éprouve
ceux qu'il aime.
Car épreuve après épreuve,
nous gagnons en maturité,
nous gagnons en sagesse,
nous gagnons en patience
pour les épreuves
qui suivront
jusqu'au retour du Christ.
C'est le sentier étroit
que le chrétien
doit arpenter ici-bas.
Il n'y a pas d'autre solution
car seul ce chemin
mène aux portes du paradis.
Jacques renouvelle donc
son encouragement
du verset 3.
Il insiste
parce qu'il sait
que la plus grande motivation
que nous pouvons avoir
pour endurer les épreuves,
pour persévérer,
en gardant un bon témoignage
tout du long,
c'est de garder les yeux fixés
sur la finalité
de nos efforts.
C'est cette même image
que Paul reprend
dans sa lettre aux Corinthiens
et que nous avons lue
en introduction de ce culte
lorsqu'il dit
que nous courons
non pas pour une couronne
de laurier corruptible
mais pour une couronne
incorruptible.
C'est cette même couronne
de vie,
c'est la vie éternelle.
Aujourd'hui,
nous souffrons.
nous transpirons.
Tout comme un athlète
transpire jour après jour
dans ses entraînements
pour gagner la compétition.
Mais nous le faisons
non seulement parce que
nous savons que la récompense
sera grande,
que cela vaut la peine,
mais surtout
parce que nous savons
que Jésus-Christ
a déjà remporté pour nous
la victoire,
en écrasant tous nos adversaires,
tous nos ennemis
sous ses pieds.
Cette couronne de vie,
c'est la vie éternelle,
c'est Jésus-Christ lui-même
et c'est pour avoir part
à la gloire de son règne
lorsqu'il reviendra
l'instaurer sur terre
que nous persévérons
dans l'épreuve.
ce que Jacques nous dit,
c'est que si nous marchons
jour après jour
avec cette perspective
en tête,
alors nous ne baisserons pas
les bras lorsque l'épreuve
viendra.
Nous serons prêts,
nous serons déterminés
parce que nos souffrances
nous plongent
dans la perspective
du glorieux retour
du Christ.
Oui, mais seulement voilà,
force est de constater,
chacun peut en témoigner,
que lorsque l'épreuve arrive,
nous ne sommes pas toujours
à la hauteur.
Même si nous sommes d'accord
avec tout ce que nous avons
dit jusque-là,
dans le verset 12,
il peut nous arriver
de manquer de patience,
de maîtrise de nous-mêmes,
de force et de volonté
dans l'épreuve.
Et Jacques le sait très bien,
c'est un pasteur,
après tout.
Et chacun d'entre nous ici présents
le sait très bien aussi.
Pour nous,
qui sommes des pécheurs,
l'épreuve est souvent
une occasion de chute.
L'épreuve est souvent
Bien qu'elle soit voulue
et utilisée par Dieu
pour notre bien à la base.
À cause du reste de corruption
qui demeure en nous,
même chez les chrétiens,
à cause de la faiblesse
de notre chair,
à cause de nos mauvais désirs
qui demeurent en nous,
l'épreuve peut se transformer
en occasion de chute,
en tentation pour nous.
Et lorsque cela arrive,
le vieil homme en nous,
notre ancienne nature,
rebelle contre Dieu,
cherche des excuses
pour justifier son péché
et pour ne pas faire face
à sa seule responsabilité.
Et c'est parce que Jacques
a le vif désir
que nous recevions tous
la couronne de vie.
Mais parce qu'il sait aussi
très bien que nous sommes faibles
et qu'il pourra
et qu'il nous arrivera
de baisser les bras
dans l'épreuve,
qu'il anticipe
dans les versets 13 et 15
les excuses
que nous pourrions donner
dans ces moments-là
pour justifier
notre péché.
Qui n'a jamais entendu,
qui n'a jamais tenu
ou au moins entendu
ce genre de discours ?
C'est beaucoup trop dur.
Même si je sais
que cela en vaut la peine,
même si je sais
que Dieu a promis
de me soutenir,
je n'y arrive pas.
C'est trop difficile.
L'épreuve dure trop longtemps,
je n'ai pas la patience.
Pourquoi Dieu
me l'inflige-t-il cela ?
C'est parce qu'il m'a mis
dans cette situation
que je pêche.
Il ne me laisse pas le choix.
C'est à cause
du caractère insupportable
de telle personne
que j'ai été poussé
à mal agir.
Ce n'est pas ma faute.
Ou encore,
je suis comme ça.
On ne se refait pas.
C'est mon éducation,
c'est ma manière d'être,
ma personnalité.
Je n'y peux rien.
Dieu,
les autres
et finalement nous-mêmes,
voilà ceux
que nous sommes prêts
à accuser
pour ne pas faire face
à notre responsabilité
lorsque nous chutons
et pêchons
dans l'épreuve.
Comment ne pas transformer
l'épreuve en tentation ?
C'est la question centrale
que nous allons nous poser
ce matin.
Comment ne pas transformer
l'épreuve
en tentation ?
Et nous allons y répondre
en trois points.
premièrement,
en ne rejetant pas
la faute sur Dieu.
Deuxièmement,
en ne rejetant pas
la faute sur les autres
et pour finir,
en apprenant à déjouer
les mécanismes
de la tentation
en nous.
L'objectif étant
qu'à la fin
de cette prédication,
nous comprenions mieux
les mécanismes
que notre chair
met en place
pour justifier
notre péché
et que nous soyons
plus équipés,
plus déterminés
à déjouer
ces mécanismes
pour le salut
de notre âme.
Relisons le verset 13.
que personne,
lorsqu'il est tenté
ou éprouvé,
ne dise
« C'est Dieu
qui me tente. »
Car comme Dieu
ne peut être tenté
par aucun mal,
aussi ne tente-t-il
personne.
Comme nous l'avons vu
dans les premiers versets
et redit en introduction
de cette prédication,
Dieu nous éprouve
pour notre bien.
Il le fait
parce qu'il nous aime
et qu'il veut
produire en nous
cette patience
qui nous conduira
jusqu'au paradis.
Donc,
nous l'affirmons
en tant que bons calvinistes,
l'épreuve,
c'est certain,
vient bien de Dieu
et son objectif
est vertueux
pour le chrétien.
Lorsque le Saint-Esprit
nous soutient
et que nous endurons
l'épreuve
avec réussite,
l'épreuve produit
son fruit vertueux
dans notre vie
et nous ressortons
grandis spirituellement.
Par le Saint-Esprit,
l'épreuve est bonne,
elle est salutaire
même pour nous.
Mais lorsque nous écoutons
plus notre chair
que le Saint-Esprit
et que nous nous laissons
conduire
par notre chair,
alors l'épreuve
se transforme en tentation.
Le péché est enfanté
et nous en ressortons
fortement diminués
spirituellement.
Ce n'est donc jamais
Dieu qui est méchant
lorsqu'il nous éprouve.
Et l'épreuve
n'est jamais intrinsèquement
mauvaise pour nous.
Mais c'est notre cœur
et notre chair
corrompus
qui transforment
l'épreuve en pierre
d'achoppement,
qui transforment l'épreuve
en occasion de chute.
Frères et sœurs,
parmi tous
ce que je vais dire ce matin,
il y a quelques phrases
que vous devez absolument
noter
et ne jamais oublier.
Et la suivante
en fait partie.
Dieu ne cherchera jamais
à détruire votre foi,
mais toujours
à la fortifier.
Dieu ne cherchera jamais
à détruire votre foi,
mais toujours
à la fortifier.
Dieu nous éprouve
pour notre bien
et non pour notre malheur.
Dieu nous éprouve
pour nous mener
à la vie
et non à la mort,
pour nous sanctifier
et non pour nous tenter.
N'oubliez jamais,
comme nous l'avons dit,
que Dieu éprouve
ce qu'il aime.
Car l'épreuve
nous discipline
et que cette discipline
paternelle, aimante,
bienveillante de Dieu
est la seule
qui nous fera persévérer
jusqu'au retour du Christ.
Les épreuves
que vous endurez patiemment
ne sont jamais
envoyées par Dieu
pour vous décourager,
pour vous blesser,
pour vous nuire.
Bien au contraire,
Dieu les utilise
pour vous faire
grandir spirituellement.
En vous faisant
abandonner
les mauvais réflexes
de votre chair
et en vous faisant
développer le fruit
de l'esprit en vous,
sans lequel personne
ne franchira
les portes du paradis.
Jacques nous interdit
très clairement
de penser,
ne serait-ce
qu'une micro-seconde,
que lorsque Dieu
nous éprouve,
il nous pousse
à pécher.
Vous pouvez aussi
noter cette phrase.
Jamais lorsque Dieu
nous éprouve,
il ne nous pousse
à pécher.
Jacques nous interdit
absolument
de faire porter
la responsabilité
de notre péché
sur la souveraineté
ou la providence
de Dieu.
Et pourtant,
combien de fois
avons-nous pu
reprocher à Dieu
de nous avoir
placés dans telle
ou telle situation
qui, selon nous
en tout cas,
nous a inévitablement
poussés à pécher.
Même si nous ne l'avons
pas dit avec nos mots,
ne l'avons-nous
pas déjà pensé ?
Je vais prendre
un exemple
et le garder
pour la suite
de cette prédication
parce qu'il est
à la fois très parlant
et malheureusement
récurrent dans nos églises.
N'avez-vous jamais
entendu un frère
ou une sœur
qui attend avec hâte
le mariage,
ce qui est une bonne chose,
dire la même chose
que cet homme
que nous appellerons
Tom,
pour l'exemple ?
J'attends depuis
trop longtemps.
Le temps passe,
mon âge avance
et je ne peux plus
me permettre
d'attendre plus.
Tous mes amis
sont déjà en couple
et moi,
Dieu ne répond pas
à mes prières.
Je suis toujours
célibataire
après toutes ces années.
En plus,
la vie seule
dans cette grande ville
est trop dure.
Je suis loin
de ma famille,
j'ai besoin
de réconfort.
Et puis,
je n'ai aucune opportunité
dans l'église.
Par contre,
au travail,
il y a cette fille
avec qui le courant
passe vraiment bien.
Je m'arrête là
pour le moment,
nous reproiserons
Tom plus tard
dans cette prédication.
Mais voici
comment cette première étape
qui consiste à accuser
la providence divine
peut être illustrée.
Il est rare
qu'un chrétien
accuse directement Dieu
de le pousser à pécher.
Par contre,
il est beaucoup plus courant
malheureusement
d'entendre un chrétien
se plaindre
des circonstances
de sa vie
qui le poussent
soi-disant
à pécher.
Autrement dit,
il est malheureusement
courant
d'entendre un chrétien
accuser la providence
de Dieu
qui ne lui donne
pas ce qu'il faut
pour rester
dans le droit chemin.
Combien de fois
avons-nous pu
nous-mêmes tomber
dans ce terrible
syllogisme ?
Dieu m'éprouve.
Or,
cette épreuve
me pousse à pécher.
Donc,
c'est Dieu
qui me pousse
à pécher.
C'est ce raisonnement
abject
que Jacques
nous interdit
formellement
de présenter
pour faire porter
à Dieu
la responsabilité
de notre péché.
Oui,
Dieu met à l'épreuve
notre foi.
Il nous teste
comme il a testé
Abraham,
Moïse,
comme il a testé
Jésus-Christ lui-même
dans le désert.
Mais jamais,
pas une seule fois,
Dieu n'a poussé
une de ses créatures
à pécher.
Cela est impossible,
dit Jacques,
car Dieu ne peut
être tenté
par aucun mal.
Aussi ne tente-t-il
personne.
Alors,
plusieurs questions
peuvent être soulevées
face à cet argument
théologique
que Jacques présente.
Premièrement,
il y a plusieurs passages
des Écritures
où il nous est dit
que Dieu est tenté.
Prenons par exemple
Exode 17,
verset 7.
Moïse donna à ce lieu
le nom de Massa
et Mériba
parce que les enfants
d'Israël
avaient contesté
et parce qu'ils avaient
tenté l'Éternel
en disant
l'Éternel est-il
au milieu de nous
ou n'y est-il pas ?
Ce verset ne dit-il pas
que Dieu peut être tenté ?
Il le dit en effet.
Mais encore une fois,
nous faisons face
à l'importance
d'attribuer le bon sens
au bon mot
dans son contexte.
Le peuple d'Israël
a en effet
de par son comportement
éprouvé Dieu.
Ils ont en quelque sorte
tenté de tenter Dieu
en contestant sa volonté.
Ils ont mis à l'épreuve
Dieu
par leur attitude.
Mais c'est tout
ce qu'ils pouvaient faire.
Jamais à un seul moment
Dieu n'a expérimenté
une once
d'inclination
vers le mal
à cause du comportement
d'Israël.
Car il est le père
des lumières.
Il n'y a en lui
aucune ombre
de variation
comme Jacques le dit
quelques versets
plus loin dans sa lettre.
Si Dieu peut en effet
être mis à l'épreuve,
il ne peut jamais,
jamais être
incliné au mal.
Et voici une troisième phrase
que je vous encourage
à noter
et à retenir.
Dans ce passage
et dans beaucoup d'autres,
c'est très important
pour cette prédication.
la tentation
est l'inclination
naturelle
et puissante
de notre cœur
à chérir
et à pratiquer
le mal.
Je répète,
la tentation
est l'inclination
naturelle
et puissante
du cœur humain
à chérir
et à pratiquer
le mal.
La tentation,
c'est l'inclination
naturelle
de notre cœur
au mal.
Dans ce sens-là,
évidemment,
Dieu ne peut être tenté.
Et nous pourrons parler
après le culte,
si vous le souhaitez,
des tentations
de Jésus-Christ
parce que ça pose
encore d'autres questions
et on n'a pas le temps
pour ça ce matin.
Mais notez que Dieu,
qui est l'essence même
du bien,
du beau,
du vrai,
impassible,
éternel
dans tous ses parfaits attributs,
ne peut en aucun cas
être incliné au mal.
Et il s'ensuit donc
qu'il ne peut pas
non plus pousser
un autre au mal
puisque évidemment,
encourager quelqu'un
à pécher,
c'est déjà péché.
Voilà donc pourquoi
l'affirmation de Jacques
est tout à fait vraie
et pertinente
et qu'elle confirme
ce que nous avons dit
plus haut,
à savoir qu'aucune
des épreuves que Dieu
ne vous envoie
ne peut être
un encouragement
à pécher,
ne peut être
une tentation.
Cela est tout simplement
impossible
au vu de l'être
même de Dieu
et de ses attributs.
Nous ne devrions
jamais oser imaginer
que Dieu
n'est pas bon.
Dieu est bon,
pur,
parfait en toute chose,
à toute occasion.
Et si l'épreuve
se transforme
en tentation
pour nous,
si nous nous sentons
poussés à pécher
lorsque nous sommes éprouvés,
la responsabilité
doit donc être
cherchée ailleurs
qu'en Dieu
et en sa providence.
Nous venons d'exclure,
Jacques vient d'exclure
cette possibilité.
et nous en venons
donc au deuxième argument
que nous pourrions
avancer pour nous
déresponsabiliser
de notre péché
dans l'épreuve.
Si ce n'est pas
à cause de Dieu
et de sa providence,
alors c'est à cause
des personnes
qui m'entourent.
C'est à cause
des autres.
Lisons
la première partie
du verset 14.
Lisons tout
le verset 14 en fait.
Après avoir écarté
toute possibilité
d'accuser Dieu,
Jacques rentre
dans le vif du sujet
en recentrant
de plus en plus
la culpabilité
de notre péché
sur nous
et sur personne d'autre.
Rappelons Tom
pour voir comment
cette étape
peut se manifester
concrètement.
Après avoir accusé
la providence de Dieu
en lui reprochant
les circonstances
de sa vie,
Tom poursuit
son argumentaire
de la manière suivante.
Cette fille au travail
est géniale.
Elle n'est pas chrétienne
mais pourtant
elle m'apporte
tellement plus
que ceux que je côtoie
à l'église.
J'ai été si souvent
déçu par les chrétiens,
si souvent rejeté
par les chrétiennes
vers qui je suis allé.
Depuis que je ne vais
plus trop à l'église,
aucun ne prend
de nouvelles de moi
mis à part un ou deux,
ils s'en fichent.
Alors que mes amis
au travail,
eux,
ils se soucient
vraiment de moi.
Merci Tom,
nous reviendrons
vers toi plus tard.
Ne vous est-il
jamais arrivé
d'accuser
une autre personne
pour justifier
votre propre péché ?
Si vous répondez non,
repentez-vous
de suite
parce que vous mentez.
Ce réflexe
est aussi naturel
que la respiration
pour l'être humain
depuis la chute
d'Adam et Ève.
Faisons un tour
en Genèse
au chapitre 3
versets 8 et 13
et voyons
les réactions
qu'Adam et Ève
ont eues
lorsque Dieu
les mit
face à leur péché.
Genèse 3
8 et 13
Alors ils entendirent
la voix
de l'Éternel Dieu
qui parcourait
le jardin
vers le soir
et l'homme
et sa femme
se cachèrent
loin de la face
de l'Éternel Dieu
au milieu
des arbres du jardin.
Et l'Éternel Dieu
appela l'homme
et lui dit
« Où es-tu ? »
Il répondit
« J'ai entendu
ta voix
dans le jardin
et j'ai eu peur
parce que je suis nu
et je me suis caché. »
Et l'Éternel Dieu
dit
« Qui t'a appris
que tu es nu ?
Est-ce que tu as mangé
de l'arbre
dont je t'avais défendu
de manger ? »
L'homme répondit
« La femme
que tu as mise
auprès de moi
m'a donné de l'arbre
et j'en ai mangé. »
Et l'Éternel Dieu
dit à la femme
« Pourquoi as-tu fait cela ? »
La femme répondit
« Le serpent
m'a séduite
et j'en ai mangé. »
Amen.
La première chose
qu'Adam fait
comme Tom
c'est blâmer
les circonstances
en disant
« J'ai entendu
ta voix
j'ai eu peur
je me suis caché. »
Puis lorsque
cette diversion
que Adam
tente
ne marche pas
il se tourne
vers sa femme
pour l'accuser
mais elle n'est
qu'un moyen
pour lui
pour mieux accuser
Dieu
finalement
qui dans la bouche
d'Adam
est le seul
vrai responsable
de son péché
puisque c'est Dieu
qui a créé la femme
c'est Dieu
qui l'a placée
à ses côtés
qui lui a donné
et c'est donc
Dieu
le responsable.
Et pour Ève
c'est la même chose
elle rejette
la faute
sur le serpent
qui a été créé
par qui ?
Par Dieu
qui est donc
le vrai responsable
de leur péché.
Depuis la chute
d'Adam et Ève
le réflexe inné
que chaque être humain
a
et que l'on peut
facilement observer
chez les plus jeunes
enfants
c'est d'accuser
les autres
d'être responsables
de leur péché.
Mais ce que nous comprenons
bien en lisant
Genèse
c'est que même
si cela semble être
un autre argument
le premier étant
d'accuser Dieu
ici
l'argument semble
d'être accusé
quelqu'un d'autre
finalement
accuser une autre personne
revient toujours
à accuser
la providence de Dieu
et donc Dieu lui-même
ce qui est interdit
par le verset 13
comme nous venons
de le voir.
Frères et sœurs
vous pourriez être
dans une église
avec les chrétiens
les moins saints
et les plus insupportables
du royaume de Dieu
hors de moi.
Non, non, non
chers assemblés
tout comme Tom
ne peut pas se justifier
en reprochant à ses frères
leur manque d'amour
et de soin
vous ne pouvez jamais
vous justifier
de votre péché
en reprochant à vos frères
leur péché.
Voici une autre phrase
courte que vous pouvez noter
Le péché d'un autre
ne justifiera jamais
le vôtre.
Le péché d'un autre
les manquements
les faiblesses d'un autre
ne justifieront jamais
votre péché.
Chacun est tenté
quand il est attiré
et amorcé
par sa propre combattise.
Nous pourrions faire
une courte parenthèse
qui me semble pertinente
ici
vu les nombreuses personnes
parmi nous
qui viennent de milieux
charismatiques ou animistes.
Pour cela
vous savez mieux que moi
à quel point
l'homme est prompt
à rejeter la faute
sur tel esprit
tel démon
telle malédiction ancestrale
telle oppression
générationnelle
etc.
Et je ne nie pas
l'existence de ces choses
ce n'est pas le sujet ici.
Je dis juste
que nous devons rester
très vigilants
pour ne pas nous servir
de ces phénomènes
comme une autre excuse
pour notre péché.
Dans certains milieux
on entend par exemple
beaucoup parler
de la sirène des eaux
qui serait
une divinité maléfique
qui pousse les hommes
à avoir une sexualité
débridée.
À d'autres
j'ai envie de dire.
Voici le cas typique
d'un homme pécheur
qui aime la luxure
qui aime la débauche
et qui n'a pas envie
d'en sortir
tout simplement
et qui se présente
comme victime
d'un prétendu démon
qui le force à vivre ainsi
qui le forcerait
à vivre ainsi.
À cet homme
je réponds à nouveau
chacun est tenté
quand il est tenté
et amorcé
par sa propre convoitise.
Vous pensiez
que nous en avions fini
avec toutes les options ?
C'est se tromper lourdement
sur la capacité
qu'a notre cœur humain
de se trouver des excuses.
Lorsque Dieu
est sa providence
lorsque les autres personnes
qui nous entourent
lorsque les démons
ou les oppressions
ne sont plus en cause.
Il nous reste malgré tout
un dernier rempart.
Une autre personne
à laquelle nous ne pensons
pas forcément
mais que nous accusons
pourtant très souvent
à notre place.
Je veux parler
de nous-mêmes.
Alors là normalement
si vous êtes logique
vous vous dites
Nathanael
il débloque complètement.
On comprend bien
depuis le début
qu'il veut nous dire
que nous sommes responsables
de notre péché
et maintenant
il nous reproche
de nous accuser nous-mêmes
de notre péché.
Ça n'a plus aucun sens.
Eh bien vous devriez comprendre
avec ces quelques
exemples de phrases
et je les ai déjà données
d'ailleurs.
Ah bah ça c'est moi
j'ai toujours été comme ça.
C'est mon éducation.
C'est les exemples
que j'ai eus
ça m'a forgé
de cette manière.
Je n'y peux rien
c'est comme ça.
Je le sais
c'est pas bien
mais qu'est-ce que j'y peux ?
Je suis comme ça.
Frères et sœurs
je ne sais pas
si vous réalisez
que ces phrases
sont peut-être
les plus graves
et les plus offensantes
qu'un chrétien
puisse prononcer
envers son Dieu.
Je suis très sérieux.
Et pourtant
beaucoup de chrétiens
disent cela.
Ils disent cela
parfois en se pensant
très spirituel
en pensant faire preuve
d'un grand discernement
d'une grande honnêteté
sur eux-mêmes
d'une grande humilité
face à leur péché.
alors qu'en réalité
tout ce qu'ils font
c'est ne s'excuser
une fois de plus
en accusant
leur chair
le vieil homme
le reste de corruption
qui demeure en eux.
Mais ne confondez pas
un seul instant cela
avec une vraie confession
une vraie repentance
une vraie contrition
une vraie humilité biblique.
Ne vous l'aurez pas vous-même
si vous avez l'habitude
de prononcer ces phrases.
Vous ne faites
que vous déresponsabilisez
une fois de plus
et pardonnez-moi
de la plus misérable
des manières
car non content
de ne pas assumer
votre péché
vous insultez
par la même occasion
le Saint-Esprit.
Lorsque vous faites face
à votre péché
que vous dites
je suis comme ça
je sais que c'est mal
mais c'est ma personnalité
ce que vous dites
en réalité
c'est
ma chair est plus forte
que le Saint-Esprit
mon péché
est plus fort
que le sang
du Christ.
Le sang du Christ
n'a pas le pouvoir
de me changer
ma chair
est plus forte
il n'y a pas
plus orgueilleux
plus insultant
envers Dieu
que ce type
de pensée
et de phrases
en apparence
remplie d'humilité.
Un chrétien
n'a tout simplement
pas le droit
de dire cela.
Vous pouvez avoir
des traits de personnalité
qui ne changeront pas
évidemment
et qui ne représentent
aucun problème
parce qu'ils ne vous conduisent
pas à pécher
mais tous les aspects
de votre personnalité
qui sont directement
un péché
ou qui vous
conduisent à pécher
vous devez les combattre
férocement
et ne leur trouver
aucune excuse.
Le sang de Jésus-Christ
a coulé
pour que votre péché
soit anéanti.
Le Saint-Esprit
œuvre en vous
pour que votre chair
soit neutralisée.
Alors pour votre bien
et pour celui
de vos frères et sœurs
ne laissez jamais entendre
que votre chair
et votre péché
sont plus forts
que l'œuvre
de Dieu
dans votre vie.
Alors si ce n'est
ni à cause de Dieu
et de sa providence
ni à cause
des autres
ni même à cause
de ma chair
soi-disant inaltérable
qui est responsable
de mon péché ?
Vous l'avez bien compris
le seul et unique
responsable
de notre péché
c'est nous-mêmes.
Nous portons
l'entière responsabilité
de notre péché
devant Dieu
et devant les hommes.
Mais sachant cela
comment le péché
se fraye-t-il
un chemin
jusqu'en nous ?
Si nous avons bien compris
ce mécanisme
d'auto-argumentation
d'auto-justification
que nous mettons en place
pour nous défendre
lorsque nous chutons
dans l'épreuve
quel est le mécanisme
du péché en nous ?
Comment se fraye-t-il
un chemin en nous ?
Pour le dire plus simplement
comment sommes-nous tentés ?
C'est très important
pour nous de comprendre
ce qu'est vraiment
la tentation
et comment elle agit
en nous
afin que nous soyons
plus à même
de l'identifier
de la combattre
et de la vaincre
dans notre vie.
Et c'est ce que nous allons
voir maintenant
à partir du verset 14.
Comment sommes-nous tentés ?
Afin de ne laisser aucun doute
à ses lecteurs
que chacun porte
l'entière responsabilité
de son péché,
Jacques illustre
ce mécanisme
par deux métaphores
très explicites
qui nous montrent
par la même occasion
comment la convoitise
mène au péché
qui lui-même
mène à la mort.
La première métaphore
est celle
de la pêche
au verset 14.
Chacun est tenté
lorsqu'il est attiré
et amorcé
par sa propre convoitise.
Le premier concept
généralement
qui nous vient en tête
lorsque nous parlons
de tentation
ce sont
les sollicitations
extérieures
à nous-mêmes
qui nous poussent
à pêcher.
N'est-ce pas ?
Nous pensons par exemple
à Satan
le tentateur
par excellence
nous pensons
au païen
qui nous encourage
à laisser tomber
la volonté de Dieu
ou à toutes
ces sollicitations
qu'on peut trouver
dans notre société
et qui attire
notre chair
qui la pousse
à pêcher.
Et la tentation
peut en effet
avoir cette signification.
Si l'on reste
dans la métaphore
de la pêche
toutes ces choses
extérieures
que j'ai mentionnées
ces choses extérieures
à nous-mêmes
sont des appâts
qui nous attire
vers le mal.
Mais la question
c'est pourquoi
sommes-nous attirés
par ces appâts ?
Parce qu'après tout
c'est bien ça le problème.
Le problème
ce n'est pas tellement
que nous soyons
entourés d'appâts
c'est que nous soyons
attirés
vers ces appâts
parce qu'ils nous
semblent bons
semblent attirants
séduisants
qu'on s'en approche
comme un poisson
s'approche
de l'appât
du pêcheur.
Là encore
frères et sœurs
nous ne pouvons
nous dédouaner
en accusant
toutes ces sources
extérieures de tentation.
Car si
elles n'excitaient
absolument rien
en nous
elles resteraient
impuissantes.
Ce que ces métaphores
ce que cette métaphore
de Jacques
nous montre
c'est que
tout ce que
ces appâts font
au final
c'est exciter
les mauvais désirs
qui sont déjà
en nous
à cause
de la corruption
du péché originel.
Jacques ne dit pas
chacun est tenté
lorsqu'il est
attiré
et amorcé
par Satan
la sirène des eaux
la société corrompue
mais bien
par sa propre
convoitise.
Frères et sœurs
nous marchons
vers l'appât
nous jouons
avec l'appât
et nous finissons
par mordre
à l'appât
parce que nous
le voulons
tout simplement.
vous savez
ce que sont
les amorces
à la pêche
puisque le verset
dit ici
amorcé
par sa propre
convoitise
ce sont des
appâts secondaires
qu'on lance
tout autour
de l'hameçon
pour attirer
le poisson
de loin
et qu'il se rapproche
de l'appât
principal.
Ce sont donc
des appâts secondaires.
Cela veut dire
que selon
cette métaphore
nous n'avons
même pas besoin
d'appât extérieur
à nous-mêmes
pour nous pousser
à pêcher.
Notre propre
convoitise
à elle seule
nous attire
et nous amorce
vers le péché.
C'est ce que dit
ce verset.
Notre convoitise
nous amorce
vers le péché.
Lorsque Tom
accuse la providence
de Dieu,
les chrétiens
ou toute autre personne
de le pousser
à transgresser
la volonté de Dieu
en entretenant
une relation
avec une non-chrétienne,
ce n'est que
pour faire diversion.
La réalité
c'est qu'il n'a besoin
de rien
ni personne
pour le pousser
à pêcher
car il est simplement
en train de laisser
toute la place
à sa propre
convoitise.
Tout comme son père
Adam
dans le jardin d'Éden,
Tom veut quelque chose
quand et comme
il le veut
même si cela
le fait agir
contre la volonté
de Dieu.
C'est tout.
Nous devons nous rendre
à l'évidence
et ne jamais
l'oublier.
Nous sommes par nature
dès notre naissance
entièrement
inclinés au mal.
Nous aimons
le mal.
notre péché,
nous aimons
l'entretenir
et nous aimons
le consommer.
Il n'y a que
le Saint-Esprit
qui peut inverser
cette tendance
en nous donnant
un cœur nouveau
et en entretenant
jour après jour
dans ce cœur nouveau
de nouveaux désirs,
de nouvelles affections,
de nouvelles attirances,
de nouveaux objectifs.
Sans la grâce
commune de Dieu
qui restreint
le péché
en l'homme,
sans la grâce
particulière
de Dieu
qui produit
du bon fruit
de l'esprit
en l'homme
qui est né
de nouveau,
les désirs
de l'homme
ne se portent
que vers le mal.
La source
de la tentation,
elle peut être
mais elle n'est
premièrement pas
extérieure
à nous-mêmes.
La source
première de tentation
dans nos vies,
c'est la convoitise
de notre cœur
corrompu
qui nous pousse
vers le péché
que nous désirons
et que nous affectionnons.
Et la deuxième
métaphore que Jacques
donne
et qui nous explique
la suite
et la fin
de ce processus
du péché
et de la tentation
en nous
au verset 15
et après
que la convoitise
a conçu,
elle enfante
le péché
et le péché
étant consommé
engendre
la mort.
Donc la métaphore
de la conception
de la naissance,
de l'engendrement.
Lorsque nous sommes
attirés par le péché,
par notre convoitise,
il est encore temps
de faire marche arrière.
C'est ce combat
contre la chair
que nous menons
chaque jour.
Lorsque,
poussés par notre orgueil,
nous voulons répondre
à la provocation.
Lorsque,
poussés par notre convoitise,
nous sommes jaloux
de la réussite
d'un frère,
etc.
Les exemples
sont nombreux.
Dieu a dit
à Cain,
certainement,
si tu agis bien,
tu relèveras ton visage
et si tu agis mal,
le péché
se couche
à la porte
et ses désirs
se portent vers toi
mais toi,
domine sur lui.
Nous sommes appelés
à dominer
notre péché
et cela
est possible.
Cela est possible
grâce au Saint-Esprit
qui abonde en nous
de ce côté-ci
de la croix
grâce à l'œuvre
du Christ.
Mais lorsque,
malheureusement,
nous laissons
notre propre convoitise
faire son chemin en nous,
nous attirer
vers l'hameçon
et que,
finalement,
nous mordons
à cet hameçon,
alors,
notre convoitise
enfante,
le péché.
Voici notre phrase
que vous pouvez noter.
le péché
dans notre vie
est l'aboutissement
de notre passivité active
face à notre propre convoitise.
Le péché
est l'aboutissement
de notre passivité active
face à notre propre convoitise.
Et la parole
est très claire
quant au salaire du péché.
C'est la mort.
Et c'est ce que Jacques
nous rappelle ici.
Le péché
étant consommé
engendre la mort.
Pour ceux
qui auraient déjà
pratiqué la pêche,
vous savez qu'il peut arriver
souvent lorsqu'on retire
l'hameçon
de la bouche du poisson,
désolé pour l'image,
mais qu'on arrache
une grande partie
de la bouche
avec les branchies,
une partie
de l'intérieur du poisson.
Cette réalité
un peu désagréable
illustre bien
ce que le péché
consommé produit en nous.
Frères et sœurs,
nous ne devrions
jamais,
jamais
considérer
que nous pouvons pêcher
sans conséquence.
Il y a de gros hameçons
qui arracheront
une grande partie
de la bouche
du poisson directement,
d'autres plus petits hameçons
qui ne vont faire
que l'entailler,
c'est vrai,
mais de nombreux
petits hameçons,
l'un après l'autre,
finiront par faire
les mêmes dégâts
qu'un seul gros.
Il n'existe pas
de petits péchés
sans conséquence.
Tous les péchés
méritent et mènent
inexorablement
à la mort éternelle.
Aussi naturel
est-il pour une femme
de mettre au monde
son enfant,
aussi naturel
il est pour le péché
d'enfanter la mort.
Si nous laissons
la place
à nos mauvais désirs,
si nous en prenons
l'habitude,
si nous cautérisons
notre conscience
et que nous laissons
la place
à notre convoitise
puis au péché,
c'est vers la mort éternelle
que nous marchons.
Avant de conclure,
j'aimerais revenir
rapidement sur Satan
que nous avons évoqué
dans une courte parenthèse.
Nous comprenons mieux
à la lumière
de ce que nous venons
de méditer
qu'elle est en réalité
la vraie force
de Satan.
La vraie force
de Satan,
elle est en nous.
C'est tout simplement
notre convoitise,
nos mauvais désirs,
notre inclination
naturelle au mal.
Si Satan
a une telle emprise
sur l'humanité,
s'il est si puissant
aujourd'hui,
c'est parce que
personne mieux que lui
ne sait qu'elle a pas
utilisé pour séduire
au mieux
notre chair.
Mais nous ne devons pas
oublier qu'il serait
totalement impuissant
si nous n'étions pas
corrompus.
C'est pour cela
qu'il ne pouvait rien
contre Dieu le Fils
qui s'est fait homme
et il ne peut rien
aujourd'hui
contre les enfants de Dieu
qui sont en Christ
et en qui Christ vit
par son esprit.
Bien sûr qu'il a encore
une certaine emprise
sur nous,
c'est indéniable
parce qu'il y a tout simplement
ce reste de corruption
en nous.
Mais nous ne devons
jamais oublier
qu'il ne pourra
plus jamais nous accuser.
Car en Jésus-Christ,
nous sommes déclarés
justes et parfaits
et que nous le serons
réellement
au jour de son retour.
lorsque nous revêtirons
notre nouveau corps
incorruptible
que nous recevrons
de ses mains.
Alors,
chers assemblés,
en attendant ce jour
glorieux
de notre glorification,
où ces exhortations
de Jacques
ne seront plus
qu'un lointain souvenir,
car nous serons alors
incapables de pécher,
que faire pour éviter
de transformer nos épreuves
en sources de tentation ?
Pour éviter d'accuser
Dieu et sa providence,
apprenons à connaître
qui est Dieu.
Apprenons à connaître
ses attributs,
ses intentions
envers nous,
les promesses
qu'il nous a faites.
Entretenons une relation
proche avec ce Dieu
qui est bon en tout temps,
qui aime ce qu'il éprouve,
qui les soutiendra
jusqu'au jour
où ils recevront
la couronne de vie
de ses propres mains.
Dieu nous éprouve,
mais ne nous tente jamais.
ne l'oubliez pas.
Il veut fortifier notre foi,
jamais la détruire.
Apprenons à considérer
nos épreuves
de cette manière,
afin qu'elles ne nous mènent
non plus à pécher,
à murmurer contre Dieu,
mais plutôt à soupirer
et à persévérer
vers la vie éternelle.
N'oublions jamais
que nous sommes en guerre
constante
contre ce reste
de corruption
qui demeure en nous
et contre ce monde
dont l'esprit
nous pousse effectivement
à pécher
et à suivre
notre chair,
ne baissons jamais
la garde,
aiguisons sans cesse
les armes spirituelles
que Dieu nous a données.
Restons vigilants,
restons alertes
afin de ne pas être surpris
lorsque notre convoitise
nous attirera
vers le mal.
réagissons lorsque c'est le cas
rapidement,
radicalement
et ne pensons jamais
que nous sommes assez forts
pour jouer
avec notre convoitise.
Beaucoup se sont crus
forts et malins,
capables de jouer
avec la passe
sans mordre à l'hameçon.
Ils ont tous fini
pendus
à la canne à pêche.
Arrêtons définitivement
de chercher des excuses
pour justifier
notre péché
et assumons
notre seule
et entière responsabilité.
Si nous péchons,
c'est parce que nous le voulons,
parce que notre cœur
est mauvais.
Il n'y a pas
d'autre raison.
Frères et sœurs,
j'ai gardé pour la fin
la phrase la plus importante
de cette prédication.
Si on vous demandait
quelle est la plus grande œuvre
que le Saint-Esprit
peut produire dans une vie,
qu'est-ce que vous répondriez ?
Est-ce que vous diriez
le don d'enseigner ?
Le don de prophétie,
il est impressionnant.
Le don de guérison,
celui de parler en langue.
Je crois que la plus grande œuvre
du Saint-Esprit
dans la vie d'un homme
est malheureusement
trop prêchée,
trop peu prêchée,
justement,
trop peu encouragée
et trop peu appréciée
à sa juste valeur.
Notez bien cela.
La plus grande œuvre
du Saint-Esprit en nous,
c'est la capacité
qu'il nous donne
à assumer
la totale responsabilité
de notre péché
devant Dieu
et devant les hommes.
À confesser
cette responsabilité
alors que la chair
nous pousse à pécher
puis à accuser les autres
d'être responsables
de notre péché
le Saint-Esprit
nous pousse
à reconnaître
notre seule
et unique responsabilité,
à nous en repentir
devant Dieu
et à nous saisir
de la justice
parfaite du Christ
afin de pratiquer
le bien
par sa grâce
et pour sa gloire.
Frères et sœurs,
nous naissons tous
avec la corruption
du péché originel
gravé dans nos gènes.
Nous sommes tous
inclinés au mal,
nous sommes tous
à cause de cela
soumis à Satan
et justement condamnés
à cause de notre péché
devant Dieu.
Il n'y a que l'œuvre
salvatrice du Dieu
trinitaire
qui peut changer cela.
Alors lorsqu'il nous arrive
de transformer
les épreuves de nos vies
en pierres d'achoppement
à cause de cette corruption
en nous,
ne laissons pas Satan
nous faire croire
que notre chair
est plus forte
que le Saint-Esprit.
Dieu ne rejette jamais
un de ses enfants
qui se repense
sincèrement
de son péché
et qui revient
à lui.
Dans ces moments-là
où le Saint-Esprit
nous convainc
de pécher,
ne rejetons pas
la faute sur autrui
ou sur Dieu
mais confessons
que nous avons péché
parce que nous l'avons voulu,
parce que nous sommes corrompus.
Suppions continuellement
le Saint-Esprit
de nous donner
de nouveaux désirs,
de nouvelles affections,
de nouvelles attirances.
Faisons tous nos efforts
pour nous entourer
de bonnes influences
qui vont nous aider
à croître en sainteté.
Faisons cela
avant que notre péché
d'engendre la mort.
Je souhaiterais terminer
par la lecture
d'un texte des Écritures
Ephésiens 2,
versets 1 à 10
qui conclura à merveille
cette prédication
en nous rappelant très bien
qui nous étions
et comment nous agissions
avant que Dieu
n'intervienne dans notre vie
et qui nous sommes aujourd'hui
en Christ
et comment nous devons agir
en tant qu'enfants de Dieu,
en tant que citoyens des cieux.
Ephésiens 2, versets 1 à 10.
Vous étiez morts
par vos offenses
et par vos péchés
dans lesquels vous marchiez
autrefois selon le train
de ce monde,
selon le prince
de la puissance de l'air,
de l'esprit
qui agit maintenant
dans les fils
de la rébellion.
Nous tous aussi,
nous étions de leur nombre
et nous vivions autrefois
selon les convoitises
de notre chair,
accomplissant les volontés
de la chair
et de nos pensées
et nous étions
par nature
des enfants de colère
comme les autres.
Mais Dieu,
mais Dieu
qui est riche
en miséricorde
à cause du grand amour
dont il nous a aimés,
nous qui étions morts
par nos offenses,
nous a rendus
à la vie
avec Christ.
C'est par grâce
que vous êtes sauvés.
Il nous a ressuscités
ensemble
et nous a fait asseoir
dans les lieux célestes
en Jésus Christ
afin de montrer
dans les siècles à venir
l'infinie richesse
de sa grâce
par sa bonté
envers nous
en Jésus Christ.
Car c'est par la grâce
que vous êtes sauvés,
par le moyen
de la foi.
Et cela ne vient pas de vous,
c'est le don de Dieu.
Ce n'est point par les œuvres
afin que personne
ne se glorifie.
car nous sommes
son ouvrage
ayant été créé
en Jésus Christ
pour de bonnes œuvres
que Dieu a préparées
d'avance
afin que nous
les pratiquions.
Amen.
Je vous invite
à vous lever,
nous allons prier.
Prions afin
de rendre grâce
à Dieu
pour sa miséricorde.
Sa miséricorde
qui nous a arrachés
à la mort
en Jésus Christ
comme nous venons
de le lire.
Prions le Saint-Esprit
pour qu'il nous sanctifie
en nous délivrant
des convoitises
de notre chair
et en nous donnant
un zèle nouveau
pour obéir
à la volonté
de notre Père.
Pour que le jour
où notre course
s'achèvera
comme nous l'avons chanté
ce matin,
nous puissions dire
non par moi
mais par Jésus Christ.
Seigneur,
ta parole dit
qu'aucun de vous
ne dise qu'il est
sans péché.
Nous confessons
que nous sommes pécheurs.
En tant que chrétiens,
nous proclamons
qu'un seul
est juste devant toi,
Dieu Créateur,
Jésus Christ,
l'agneau de Dieu
qui ôte le péché
du monde.
Lui seul,
étant vraiment Dieu
et vraiment homme,
a pu mener
une vie d'obéissance
parfaite devant toi,
se rendant obéissant
jusqu'à la mort
de la croix.
Cette croix
est notre étendard,
celui que nous brandissons
lorsque l'ennemi
nous accuse
d'être encore corrompu
et condamné
devant le Dieu
des armées.
Car sans cet étendard,
trempé dans le sang
pur du Christ,
Satan a raison
de nous accuser.
Tout autre étendard
ne vaut rien
devant toi,
Seigneur,
car il n'y a
qu'un seul nom
par lequel un homme
puisse être sauvé,
le nom glorieux
de Jésus Christ.
C'est lui seul
qui a mené
une vie de justice
parfaite à notre place.
Lui seul
qui a offert son corps
en sacrifice parfait
pour nous purifier.
Lui seul
qui a mérité
la résurrection
et la vie éternelle
et l'entrée au paradis
en tant qu'homme.
Et la merveille
de l'Évangile,
c'est que tout ce que
le Fils de Dieu
a accompli
et mérité
nous est offert
par grâce
et par le moyen
de la foi.
Chaque jour,
nous nous confions
en l'œuvre parfaite
et achevée
de Jésus Christ.
C'est à elle
que nous retournons
lorsqu'il nous arrive
encore de pécher
contre toi,
notre Père,
en cédant
à nos mauvais désirs.
Saint-Esprit,
aide-nous à vivre
des vies
qui honorent notre Père
qui a offert
son propre Fils
en sacrifice
pour que nous soyons
réconciliés avec lui.
Garde-nous
dans la sainteté,
en pensée,
en mots
et en actes,
afin que nos cœurs,
nos corps
ne souillent pas
la présence du Christ
en nous
à cause de notre péché.
Soutiens-nous
au milieu de l'épreuve
afin que nous ne la transformions
pas en occasion de chute
mais que par la force
que tu nous donneras,
Saint-Esprit,
elle soit pour nous
l'occasion de démontrer
l'amour que nous avons
pour Jésus Christ
par notre obéissance fidèle.
C'est en son nom
que nous prions.
Amen.
Je vous souhaite
un bon dimanche
et une bonne semaine
à tous.
Merci.